while we're on the subject of the
environment massive story probably one
of the most important stories in this
country Monsanto's Roundup the active
ingredient in roundup glyphosate has
been linked by independent study after
independent study to all kinds of forms
of cancer kidney diseases liver diseases
neurological diseases birth defects
non-hodgkins lymphoma in fact the recent
trial that just concluded where the jury
awarded the plaintiff I think was 209
million dollars after they determined
that his non-hodgkins lymphoma was
linked to his exposure to Roundup as a
school groundskeeper 289 million dollars
the jury determined that Monsanto
covered up these dangers they knew about
them and all of that so that's what's
happening with that Monsanto is
currently facing thousands of lawsuits
over people who say that they have been
injured developed cancer or other
illnesses from exposure to glyphosate in
roundup I'm telling you that to tell you
this according to recent studies and
these studies Believe It or Not have
actually been coming out since I believe
January of this year glyphosate is now
being found in some of the most popular
foods in this country the latest study
came from the Environmental Working
Group where they found that there were
unsafe levels of glyphosate in pretty
much every oat or wheat based breakfast
product here in the United States
including blockbuster sellers like
cheerio of Cheerios granola bars baby
formula in case you're not aware of the
entire Monsanto story this is a story I
love to tell it's one I know very well I
have helped with Mike Papantonio who is
handling these lawsuits and I want
everybody to understand just how
deceitful Monsanto truly is in terms of
covering up for their glyphosate this is
a product that pulls in about four
billion dollars a year just roundup for
Monsanto could they have known for
decades now
internal studies going back to at least
the 80s if not before that showing that
yeah roundup glyphosate in lab animals
they were developing tumors they were
getting cancers they were having kidney
failure so in the early 90s the EPA
comes out and says okay
Monsanto we're gonna have to go ahead
and list glyphosate as a probable human
carcinogen and they did that
there's listed as such for a few years
but then the lobbying from Monsanto
eventually convinced the EPA to drop
that probable or possible human
carcinogen so then a few years ago when
the International Agency for research on
cancer with the World Health
Organization ruled that glyphosate was a
probable human carcinogen Monsanto began
attacking the World Health Organization
they got Republicans actually earlier
this year to threaten to cut funding to
the World Health Organization if they
didn't declassify glyphosate as a
probable human carcinogen Monsanto
created front groups the glyphosate task
force to go out there and tell us just
how safe glyphosate is hell it's almost
safe in us you could just drink a glass
of it of course when offered to do so in
several documentaries nobody from
Monsanto was actually willing to do that
they got online they hired paid trolls
to go after anyone online who dare say
something negative about roundup and how
dangerous it is yet every independent
study ones not funded by Monsanto has
shown that yeah this stuff is going to
cause massive health problems that could
lead to death when this stuff gets in
human beings roundup is so potent that
if you get a drop on your skin it is
detectable in your urine stream within
30 minutes this stuff is toxic and
here's the problem this is why these
studies showing that it's in all of our
foods are so important the reason GMOs
even exist is because they were created
by Monsanto in order to create crops
that were resistant to Roundup being
sprayed on them and now that we have
these GMOs to GMO wheat oats you know
all kinds of things like that
grains basically we can go out there we
can just hose them down with roundup to
kill all the weeds and it won't hurt the
plants at all but that roundup is on the
plants it's on the produce so when you
take that and then you make a food
product out of it you make a bread you
make a cereal you you make baby formula
or baby food you make beer and wine
which is also now contaminated with
glyphosate the most popular brands in
the country contaminated with glyphosate
it's everywhere because this produce
that is being sprayed with glyphosate is
basically the basis of our food chain
here in the United States they feed it
to livestock so you go out say yeah I'm
not gonna have grains it's contaminated
with glyphosate give me a steak what do
you think the cows been eating I'm gonna
have some nice bacon what do you think
the pigs been eating this stuff is
everywhere it's in all our food it's in
our bodies right now and chances are if
you've had anything to eat today
you've ingested some of Monsanto's
glyphosate poison and on that incredibly
depressing note we wrapped things up for
today coming up on today's bonus show
though got some great stuff a Republican
congressman is blaming his corruption on
climate change got that and much more
but I want to thank David very much for
letting me sit in if you want more from
me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire you
can follow me on twitter at baron
balance that's farr Oh n ba la in CED
it's the same on Facebook and Instagram
so if you want to follow me there that's
where I am thanks again to David and his
entire staff I'll be back with you
tomorrow have a great evening